takaterin is a plant-based mexican  eatery we have all the traditional  mexican dishes  it just happens to be vegan all our  cheeses are vegan we didn't use any  dairy  no eggs no eggs even like our beer and  wine is vegan which a lot of people  don't even know that that's vegan as  well a very popular item right now we  will be our berea platter iberia is very  hot right now which is four tacos on a  corn tortilla with melted cheese our  iberia mating house with beyond and  jackfruit and then it comes with a  little soup with garbanzo beans inside  and you just like dip the taco in the  soup and you eat it fantastic so we're  super excited that we're able to open  the doors  at the beginning of last week but we  wanted to provide an environment where  people feel comfortable comfortable and  where people feel they belong we  are very friendly with all our customers  we know them by name we say welcome back  but we always make sure that it's not  just the food it's an experience